[Music]
that's joe douglas the jets general
manager with some high praise for jets
coach
adam gase now look
let's be fair here i mean chris you and
i have both been defending adam gase all
week long in the aftermath of the shots
that jamal adams took
at him on friday that was the precursor
to the jamal adams trade although that
trade was happening with or without
those shots
let's but we need to be we need to be
fair and balanced here
joe douglas was the hand-picked gm by
adam gase
i mean as soon as mike mckagne was fired
the first thought was and the first
reports were that gase was going to get
douglas in there as the gm so i don't
expect douglas
to dump on adam gase i expect douglas to
defend adam gase
but that's a key ingredient to having a
successful franchise sure
the coach and the gm on the same page
the coach and the gm
tied together like you know the old
three-legged race that you would see at
a picnic
that's how the coach and the gm have to
be the right leg of one is tied to the
left leg or the other and they either
succeed together or they fall flat on
their faces
so of all the things you could say about
the jets that they have wrong
and they have plenty wrong that they're
trying to remedy the fact that the
coach and the gm are on the same page
and they're not going to undermine each
other
they're not going to say bad things
about each other they're not going to
try to set the other one up to be fired
that's something that plenty of bad
teams don't have and it's one of the
ingredients that you need in order to
turn a team around well yeah i mean i
think you just
the proof's in the pudding just look at
the teams that have been
like towards the top of the nfl and in
the playoff conversation last few years
i mean look the top three teams in the
afc from last year that just
speaks to it the patriots the chiefs the
ravens bam
whoa example that said done there you
know we just talked about john lynch and
kyle shanahan
the new orleans saints been really good
the last four or five years mickey
loomis sean payton bam
you know the philadelphia eagles what
we're seeing there so
you're minnesota vikings i know it's not
super bowls and everything you want it
to be but
there's a good relationship there
between spielman and zimmer so
yes this is how a successful
organization is built and that's the way
it goes
and yes sure like you said joe douglas
is going to stick up for adam gase
there's a personal history there and yes
i'm sure he was a big part of hiring him
but that doesn't mean what he said
wasn't true you know that's what i think
bothered
you know me what bothered me about last
week is just the fact that jamal adams
everybody here in new york oh he's a big
mouth he's a big mouth we need to get
over him and then he talks about adam
gase and everyone's like
what he's saying is the word of law and
now let's talk about it because that's
real
and it's like what and you know some
idiot local writers up here jumped on
the bandwagon with jim ball adams and
that was
you know bullcrap but this is a team
that was in a crappy situation
and they haven't had talent to support
sam darnold and
they're trying to build that and an
offensive line and
hey you know there's there's a lot to
rebuild here
so the defense has got something there's
no doubt about that
and without jamal adams it's still i
think it'll be a good defense greg
williams a good defensive coordinator
it is going to be about adam gase and
his offense they were last in football
last year
it's got to be better this year and if
it is better this year
i think they're a team that can be a
pain in the butt for the afc east and a
lot of the
other teams in in the nfl one is going
to come down to the quarterback last
year sam darnold exited early
with mono and the backup plans were not
successful
before you knew it the team had fallen
apart and then darnold was back that
monday night game against the patriots
where
the mic'd up segment had him admitting
that he's seeing
ghosts which is not an unrealistic
dynamic in football it happens from time
to time
right confused and uh you know i think
the team
made a bigger deal about that than they
should have by complaining about the use
of the audio i mean
it happens it's part of the development
and as darnold and gase work together
more
we we see what darnold can become
whatever his ceiling is gates is going
to get him there because we've seen gays
do that with other quarterbacks he knows
how to get the best out of the guys that
he has because
he's not going to say this is my offense
thou shalt run it
he's going to say what do you like to do
and let's showcase what you do well
right and let's stay away from the
things you don't do well i mean he was
part of the
the coaching staff that had to rip up
the playbook and
come up with something for tim tebow
right back in denver in 2011 and it
worked they made it to the final eight
with a guy who had no business playing
quarterback in the nfl
so gays knows how to get the most out of
a quarterback and this is the year where
we see
how much he can get out of sam darnold
yeah no no doubt i mean sam donald's a
franchise quarterback i mean
the big thing is we just got to see sam
darnold go through the meat and potatoes
of the schedule
or the really tough part of the schedule
we haven't seen that yet really it's
rookie year
he hurt his foot he kind of missed you
know a big chunk of the schedule there
and then got to come in
at the very end of the season last year
by the time he got back in the lineup
the year was over you know so the
pressure was off the team but i've liked
what i've seen from sam darnold
certainly
i mean really quick release great feat
in the pocket
i know he's smart he's a good leader all
that and adam gase
you know adam gases like you said the
offense has everything
you know but the big thing is is the
talent there is there enough talent
there
yet for us to really see the true
picture of
sam darnold you know is there enough
pass protection are guys like prashad
perryman and josh
josh doxon to help out of jameson cram
uh jamison crowder and that offense this
year i don't know those are two guys
that
were risky value signings that yeah
prashad perryman showed some
some talent last year finally josh
jackson if you know a
first round pick who's never developed
but that's how joe douglas has had to go
about by
you know rebuilding this team a little
bit he did a good job in finding some
value signings on the offensive line but
you know we don't get to see what
le'veon bell and sam darnold are really
doing
or what they're really capable of until
there's more talent around them
and i think there's enough this year to
see it
so you know that'll be the big thing and
i think that's what everybody's gonna be
watching because gase is an offensive
coach and a guru and all that
last year it was an unbelievably tough
start of the schedule
guess what this year mike it's a pretty
damn tough start of the schedule
and that's where i just go man it's
going to be important for them to get
off
early offensively and as a team to
at buffalo 49ers come to town then it's
at the indianapolis colts and then the
denver broncos i mean i think those are
four teams we all look at go
damn i think they're going to be pretty
good this year that's not going to be
easy
and it's going to be on gas and that
coaching staff to find some ways whether
it's trick plays or whatever
to jump start that team early to give
them some confidence and maybe steal one
of those wins against a team that
is probably better than them hey when
you consider they're playing all the
teams of the nfc west and all the teams
of the afc
west yikes will be a long year for all
of the teams in the
afc east all right best case worst case
for the
2020 jets considering that schedule that
we just looked at
yeah i mean you know i i don't look at
again i don't think i can look at the
jets and go
realistically think oh i think they'll
be competing for a wild card spot
or something like that i don't think
they're there yet no
i think they're going in the right
direction but i think realistically i
look at it as a team that
you know maybe was in the wild card race
like in mid-november
right but you know just they're not good
enough or consistent enough and i look
at like best case scenario being
eight and eight or maybe a nine and
seven
something like that but not in the
playoffs uh and then worst case
yeah i guess i look at it and just go
okay offense fell apart
some of these guys didn't work and
they're missing jamal adams and they're
back at four and twelve and drafting in
the top five or six in the nfl
draft but chris eight and eight or nine
and seven
i know a team in position for good this
year i know
now that we have that seventh playoff
seed i think
that what's going to come into sharper
focus
is that scheduling formula that rotates
every year you've got two rotations
you're rotating through your own
conference
every year playing if you're the jets
you're playing the north then the south
then the west
and then you've got the other conference
rotation with all four divisions you
play all four teams
you're going to have that nightmare year
from time to time it's going to make it
very difficult
to compete for a wild card berth the
four teams of the afc east are going to
have a hard time this year
positioning themselves for that five
six or seven seed because they all have
to play
the afc west they all have to play the
nfc west
and that that inequity in scheduling
as we get deeper and deeper into this
seven team field per
conference that's going to become more
and more of a talking point this year it
doesn't matter because of the pandemic
in future years keep an eye on that all
right we got to take a break when we
return now the clyde edwards hillare
is the top guy in kansas city in the
back field
we're going to draft our offensive
rookie of the year candidates we'll do
that next here on pro football talk
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports